الحمد
[Silence]
الذي
خير الملك
[Silence]
الا لمن ارتضى
وهم من خشيته مشفقون
ومن يقل منهم اني اله
دونه فذلك نجزيه جهنم
كذلك نجزي الظالمين
اولم ير الذين كفروا ان السما السماوات
والارض كانتا رتقا
كانتا رتقا ففتقناهما
وجعلنا من الماء
كل شيء حي افلا يؤمنون
وجعلنا في الارض رواسي ان تميد بهم وجعلنا
فيها فجاجا سبلا
وجعلنا فيها فجاجا
سبلا لعلهم يهتدون
وجعلنا السماء
سقفا محفوظا
وهم عن اياتها معرضون
وهو الذي خلق السماوات وهو الذي خلق الليل
والنهار والشمس والقمر
كل في فلك
يسبحون
وما جعلنا لبشر من قبلك الخلد افان مت فهم
الخالدون
كل نفس ذائقه
الموت
ونبلوكم
بالشر والخير فتنه والينا ترجعون
واذا راك الذين كفروا ان يتخذونك الا هزوا
ان يتخذونك
الا هزوا اهذا الذي اهذا الذي يذكر الهتكم
وهم بذكر الرحمن هم كافرون
خلق انسان
من عجل ساريكم اياتي فلا تستعجلون
ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم صادقين
لو يعلم الذين كفروا حين لا يكفون عن
وجوههم
النار ولا عن ظهورهم
ولا هم ينصرون
بل تاتيهم بقته فتبهتهم فلا يستطيعون
فلا يستطيعون ردها
ولا هم ينظرون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ولقد استهزئ برسل من قبلك
فحاق بالذين سخروا منهم ما كانوا به
يستهزئون
قل منلاكم
بالليل والنهار
من الرحمن
قللاكم
بالليل والنهار
من الرحمن
بل هم عن ذكر ربهم معرضون
ام لهم الهه تمنعهم من دوننا
لا يستطيعون نصرهم
ولا انفسهم
ينصرون
[Arabic recitation]
لا يستطيعون نصر انفسهم
ولا هم ينص صرون ولاهم منا يصحبون
[Arabic recitation]
بل متعنا هؤلاء
واباءهم
حتى طال عليهم العمر
افلا يرون انا ناتي الارض ننقصها
من اطرافها
افهم الغالبون
قل انما انذركم
بالوحي
ولا يسمع الصم الدعاء
اذا هم ين
ولا يستطيع ولا يستطيع ولا يسمع الصم
الدعاء اذا ما
[Arabic recitation]
اذا هم ينذ
اذا ما ينذرون
[Arabic recitation]
ولئن مستهم نفحه من عذاب ربك ليقولن
ليقولن
يا ويلنا
ولئن مستهم نفحه من عذاب ربك ليقولن
يا ويلنا انا كنا
ظالمين
ونضع الموازين القسط ليوم القيامه فلا
يظلم فلا تظلم نفس شيئا
وان كان مثقال حبه من خردل اتينا بها وكفى
بنا حاسبين
ولقد اتينا موسى موسى وهارون الفرقان
وضياءه
وذكرا للمتقين
الذين يخشون ربهم بالغيب وهم من الساعه
مشفقون
وهذا ذكر مبارك انزلناه
افانتم
له منكرون
الله
اكبر
سمع الله
لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
الايات كما
لار الايه كلها
كلها وانا بسمعها عشان انا ماعكش انت وانا
نفس
عجب
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ين
امين
ولقد اتينا ابراهيم رشده من قبل وكنا به
عالمين
اذ قال لابيه وقومه ما هذه التماثيل
التي انتم لها عاكفون
قالوا وجدنا اباءنا
لها عابدين
قال لقد كنتم انتم واباؤكم
في ضلال مبين
قالوا اجئتنا بالحق ام انت من اللاعبين
قال بل ربك
رب السماوات والارض الذي فطرهن
وانا على ذلكم من الشاهدين
وت الله لاكيدن
اصنامكم
بعد ان تولوا مدبرين
فجعلهم جذاا الا كبيرا لهم لعلهم اليه
يرجعون
قالوا من فعل هذا بالهتنا
انه
لمن الظالمين
قالوا سمعنا فتى يذكرهم يقال له ابراهيم
قالوا فاتوا به على اعين الناس لعلهم
يشهدون
قالوا انت فعلت هذا بالهتنا يا ابراهيم
قال بل فعله كبيرهم هذا فاسالوهم ان كانوا
ينطقون
فرجعوا الى انفسهم
فقالوا انكم انتم الظالمون
ثم نكسوا على رؤوس
لقد علمت ما هؤلاء
ينطقون
قال افتعبدون
من دون الله ما لا ينفعكم
شيئا ولا يضركم
اف لكم ولما تعبدون من دون الله افلا
تعقلون
قالوا حر قوه وانصروا الهتكم ان كنتم
فاعلين
قلنا يا نار كوني بردا وسلاما على ابراهيم
وارادوا به كيدا فجعلناهم
الاخسرين
ونجيناه ولوطا الى الارض التي باركنا فيها
للعالمين
ووهبنا له اسحاق ويعقوب نافله
وكلا
جعلنا صالحين
وجعلناهم
ائمه
يهدون بامرنا واوحينا لهم واوحينا اليهم
فعل الخيرات واقام الصلاه وايتاء
الزكاه
وكانوا لنا خاشعين
وكانوا لنا عابدين
ولوطا اتيناه حكما وعلما
ونجيناه من القريه التي كانت تعمل الخبائث
انهم
كانوا قوم سوء
فاسقين
وادخلنا ناه في رحمتنا انه من الصالحين
ونوحا اذ نادى من قبل فاستجبنا له
فاستجبنا له فنجيناه
واهله من الكرب العظيم ونصرناه من القوم
الذين كذبوا باياتنا
انهم
قوم انهم قوم سوء فاغرقناهم
اجمعين
وداوود وسليمان اذ يحكمان في الحرث
وداوود وسليمان اذ يحكمان في الحرث اذ
نفشت فيه غنم القوم
وكنا
لحكمهم شاهدين
ففهمناها
سلي سليمان وكلا اتينا حكما وعلما
وسخرنا مع داوود الجبال يسبحن والطير وكنا
فاعلين
وعلمناه صنعه لبوس لكم لتحصنكم
من باسكم
فهل انتم
شاكرون
ولسليمان الريح عاصفه
تجري بامره
تجري بامره الى الارض التي باركنا فيها
وكنا
لهم وكنا بكل شيء عالمين
ومن الشياطين من يغوصون له ويعملون عملا
دون ذلك
وكن انا
لهم حافظين
[Arabic recitation]
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال ضالين
امين
وايوب اذ نادى ربه اني مسني الضر وانت
ارحم الراحمين
فاستجبنا له فكشفنا ما به من ضر واتيناه
واتيناه اهله ومثلهم
معهم رحمه من عندنا
وذكرى للعابدين
واسماعيل وادريس وذا الكفل كل من الصابرين
وادخلناهم
في رحمتنا انهم من الصالحين
وذا النون اذ ذهب مغاضبا
فظن ان لن نقدر عليه فنادى
فنادى في الظلمات ان لا اله الا انت
سبحانك اني كنت من الظالمين
فاستجبنا له وكشفنا فاستجبنا له ونجيناه
من الغنم
وكذلك ننجي
المؤمنين
وزكريا اذ نادى ربه رب لا تذرني فردا
رب لا تذرني فردا وانت
خير الوارثين
فاستجبنا له ووهبنا له يحيى واصلحنا له
زوجه انهم كانوا يسارعون في الخيرات
انهم كانوا يسارعون في الخيرات ويدعوننا
رغبا ورهبا
وكانوا لنا خاشعين
والتي احصنت فرجها فنفخنا فيها من روحنا
وجعلناها وابنها
ايه للعالمين
ان هذه امتكم امه
واحده
وانا ربكم فاعبدون
وتقطعوا امرهم بينهم كل الينا راجعون
فمن يعمل من الصالحات وهو مؤمن فلا كفران
لسعيه
فلا كفران لسعيه وانا
له كاتبون
وحرام على قريه اهلكناها
انهم لا يرجعون
حتى اذا فتحت ياجوج وماجوج وهم من كل حدب
ينسلون
واقترب الوعد الحق
فاذا هي شاخصه ابصار الذين كفروا يا ويلنا
يا ويلنا قد كنا في غفله من هذا بل كنا
ظالمين
انكم وما تعبدون من دون الله حصب جهنم
حصب جهنم
انتم لها واردون
لو كان هؤلاء
الهه
ما وردوها وكل فيها خالدون
لهم فيها زفير وهم فيها لا يسمعون
ان الذين سبقت لهم م الحسن نا اولئك عنها
مبعدون
لا يسمعون حسيسها
وهم فيما اشتهت انفسهم
خالدون
لا يحزنهم الفزع الاكبر وتتلقاهم
الملائكه
وتتلقاهم
هذا يومكم الذي كنتم توعدون
يوم نطوي السماء
كطي السجل للكتب
كما بدانا اول خلق نعيده
وعدا علينا انا
كنا فاعلين
ولقد كتبنا في الزبور من بعد الذكر ان
الارض
ان الارض يرثها عبادي الصالحون
ان في هذا لبلاغا لقوم عابدين
وما ارسلناك الا رحمه للعالمين
قل انما يوحى الي انما الهكم اله
واحد
فهل انتم
مسلمون
فان تولوا فقل اذنتكم
على سواء
وان ادري اقريب ام بعيد ما توعدون
انه يعلم الجهر من القول ويعلم ما تكتمون
وان ادري لعله فتنه لكم ومتاع الى حين
قال رب احكم
بالحق
وربنا الرحمن المستعان
على ما تصفون
[Arabic recitation]
لمن حمده
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
جزاك الله
عشان
[Silence]
بس كان
نفس الشي المقطع
مسموح بس انا صوتي مسموح
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
اعانك الله اعانك الله
اعانك
كام
[Silence]
بسم
المفروض اجيبلك بس
لو في عصير قصفت
بثر في الحنجره الحنجره لازم اطال يعني
ذهبيه ولازم اللي عندهم حنجره ذهبيه
[Arabic recitation]
الشيطان الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
يا ايها الناس اتقوا ربكم ان زلزله الساعه
شيء عظيم
يوم ترونها تذهل كل مرضعه عما ارضعت وتضع
كل ذات حمل حملها وترى الناس سكارى وما هم
بسكارى ولكن عذاب الله شديد
ومن الناس من يجادل في الله بغير علم
ويتبع كل شيطان مريد
كتب عليه انه من توله له كتب عليه انه من
تولاه فانه يضله ويهديه الى عذاب السعير
يا ايها الناس ان كنتم في ريب من البعث
فانا خلقناكم من تراب ثم من نطفه ثم من
علقه
ثم من علقه ثم من نضغه مخلقه
وغير مخلقه لنبين لكم ونقر في الارحام ما
نشاء
الى اجل مسمى
ثم نخرجكم طفلا ثم لتبلغوا اشدكم ومنكم من
يتوفى ومنكم من يرد الى افضل العمر لكي لا
يعلم من بعد علم شيئا
وترى الارض هامده فاذا انزلنا عليها الماء
اهتزت وربت وانبتت من كل زوج بهي
ذلك بان الله هو الحق وانه يحيي الموتى
وانه على كل شيء قدير
وان الساعه اتيه لا ريب فيها وان الله
يبعث من في القب قبور
ومن الناس من يجادل في الله بغير علم ولا
هدى ولا كتاب منير
ثاني عطفه ليضل عن سبيل الله
له في الدنيا خزي ونذيقه يوم القيامه عذاب
الحريق
ذلك بما قدمت يداك وان الله ليس بظلام
للعبيد
ومن الناس من يعبد الله على حرف فان اصابه
خير اطمان به وان اصابته فتنه انقلب على
وجهه
خسر الدنيا والاخره
ذلك هو الخسران المبين
يدعو من دون الله ما لا يضره وما لا ينفعه
ذلك هو الضلال البعيد
يدعو من يدعو لمن ضره اقرب من نفعه لبئس
المولى ولبئس العشيب
ان الله يدخل الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار
ان الله يفعل ما يريد
من كان يظن ان لن ينصره الله في الدنيا
والاخره فليمدد بسبب الى السماء ثم ليقطع
ثم ليقطع فلينظر هل يذهبن كيده ما يغيظ
وكذلك انزلناه ايات بينات
وان الله يهدي من يريد
ان الذين امنوا والذين هادوا والصابئين
والنصارى
والمجوس والذين اشركوا ان الله يفصل بينهم
يوم القيامه
ان الله على كل شيء شهيد
الم تر ان الله يسجد له من في السماوات
ومن في الارض والشمس والقمر والنجوم
والجبال والشجر والدواب
وكثير من الناس
وكثير حق عليه العذاب
ومن يهن الله فما له من مكرم ان الله يفعل
ما يشاء
الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
هذان خصمان اختصموا في ربهم فالذين كفروا
قطعت لهم ثياب من نار يصب من فوق رؤوسهم
الحميم
يصهر به ما في بطونهم والجلود
ولهم مقامع من حديد
كلما ارادوا ان يخرجوا منها من غم اعيدوا
فيها وذوقوا عذاب الحريق
ان الله يدخل الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
جنات تجري من تحتها انهار
يحلون فيها من اساور من ذهب ولؤلؤا
ولباسهم فيها حرير
وهدوا الى الطيب من القول
وهدوا الى صراط الحميد
الله اكبر
سميع سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط صراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان الذين كفروا ويصدون عن سبيل الله
والمسجد الحرام الذي جعلناه للناس سواء
ان العاكف فيه والباد
ومن يرد فيه بالحاد بظلم نذقه من عذاب
اليم
واذ بوانا لابراهيم مكان البيت الا تشرك
بي شيئا وطهر بيتي
وطهر بيتي للطائفين
والقائمين
والركع السجود
واذن
في الناس بالحج ياتوك رجالا وعلى كل ضامر
ياتين من كل فج عميق
ليشهدوا منافع لهم ويذكروا اسم الله في
ايام معلومات على ما رزقهم من بهيمه
الانعام
فكلوا منها واطعموا البائس الفقير
ثم ليقضوا فثهم وليوفوا نذورهم وليطوفوا
بالبيت العتيق
ذلك ومن يعظم حرمات الله فهو خير له عند
ربه
واحلت لكم الانعام الا ما يتلى عليكم
فاجتنبوا الرجس من الاوثان واجتنبوا قول
الزور
حنفاء لله غير مشركين
به ومن يشرك بالله فكانما خر من السماء
فتخطفه الطير او تهوي به الريح
فتخطفه الطير او تهوي به الريح في مكان
سحيق
ذلك ومن يعظم شعائر الله فانها من تقوى
القلوب
لكم فيها منا نافع الى اجل مسملها
الى البيت العتيق
ولكل امه جعلنا من سكن ليذكروا اسم الله
على ما رزقهم من بهيمه الانعام
فالهكم اله واحد فله اسلموا وبشر المخبتين
الذين اذا ذكر ذكر الله وجلت قلوبهم والم
الذين اذا ذكر الله وجلت قلوبهم والصابرين
على ما اصابهم والمقيم الصلاه ومما
رزقناهم ينفقون
والبدن جعلناها لكم من شعائر الله لكم
فيها خير
فاذكروا اسم الله عليها صواب واف
فاذا وجبت جنوبها فكلوا منها واطعموا
القانع والمعتر
كذلك سخرناها لكم لعلكم تشكرون
لن ينال الله لحومها ولا دماؤها ولكن
يناله التقوى منكم كذلك سخرها لكم لتكبروا
الله على ما هداكم
كذلك سخرها لكم لتكبروا الله على ما هداكم
وبشر المحسنين
الله
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
[Arabic recitation]
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ان الله يدافع عن الذين امنوا ان الله لا
يحب كل خوان كفور
اذن للذين يقاتلون بانهم ظلموا وان الله
على نصرهم لقدير
الذين اخرجوا من ديارهم بغير حق الا ان
يقولوا ربنا
ولولا دفع الله الناس بعضهم ببعض لهدمت
صوامع وبيع وصلوات ومسا ساجد يذكر فيها
يذكر فيها اسم الله كثيرا ولينصرن
الله من ينصره
ان الله لقوي عزيز
الذين ان مكناهم في الارض اقاموا الصلاه
واتوا الزكاه وامروا بالمعروف ونهوا عن
المنكر ولله عاقبه الامور
وان يكذبوك فقد كذبت قبلهم قوم نوح وعاد
وثمود
وقوم ابراهيم وقوم لوط واصحاب مدين وكذب
موسى فامليت للكافرين ثم اخذتهم فكيف كان
نكير
فكاي من قريه اهلكناها وهي ظالمه فهي
خاويه على عروشها
وبئر معطله وقصر مشيد
افلم يسيروا في الارض فتكون لهم قلوب
يعقلون بها او اذان يسمعون بها فانها لا
تعمى الابصار ولكن تعمى القلوب التي في
الصدور
ويستعجلونك بالعذاب ولن يخلف الله وعده ان
يوما عند ربك كالف سنه مما تعدون
وكاي من قريه امليت لها وهي ظالمه ثم
اخذتها والي المصير
قل يا ايها الناس انما انا لكم نذير مبين
فذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات لهم مغفره
ورزق رزق كريم
والذين سعوا في اياتنا معاجزين فاولئك
اصحاب الجحيم
والذين سعوا في اياتنا معاجزين اولئك
وما ارسلنا من قبلك من رسول ولا نبي الا
اذا تمنى القى الشيطان في امنيه نيته
فينسخ الله ما يلقي الشيطان ثم يحكم الله
اياته والله عليم حكيم
ليجعل ما يلقي الشيطان فتنه للذين في
قلوبهم مرض والقاسيه قلوبهم وان الظالمين
لفي شقاق بعيد
وليعلم الذين اوتوا العلم انه الحق من
ربهم فيؤمنوا به فتخبت له قلوبهم
وليعلم الذين اوتوا العلم انه الحق من ربك
فيؤمنوا به فتخبت له قلوبهم
وان الله لهادي الذين امنوا الى صراط
مستقيم
ولا يزال الذين كفروا في مريه منه حتى
تاتيهم الساعه بغته او ياتيهم عذاب يوم
عقيم
الملك يومئذ لله يحكم بينهم فالذين امنوا
وعملوا الصالحات في جنات النعيم
والذين كفروا وكذبوا باياتنا فاولئك
لهم عذاب مهين
والذين هاجروا في سبيل الله ثم اقتلوا او
ماتوا ليرزقنهم
الله رزقا حسنا
وان الله لهو خير الرازقين
ليدخلنهم
مدخلا يرضونه
وان الله لعليم حليم
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ذلك ومن عاقب بمثل ما عوقب به ثم بغي عليه
لينصرنه الله
ان الله لعفو غفور ذلك بان الله يولج
الليل في النهار ويولج النهار في الليل
وان الله سميع بصير
ذلك بان الله هو الحق وان ما يدعون من
دونه هو الباطل وان الله هو العلي الكبير
الم تر ان الله انزل من السماء ماء ماء
فتصبح الارض مخضره
ان الله لطيف خبير
له ما في السماوات وما في الارض وان الله
لهو الغني الحميد
الم تر ان الله سخر لكم ما في الارض
والفلك تجري في البحر بامره ويمسك السماء
ان تقع على الارض الا باذنه
ان الله بالناس لرؤوف رحيم
وهو الذي احياكم ثم يميتكم ثم يحييكم
ان الانسان لكفور
لكل امه جعلنا من سكنهم ناسكوه فلا
ينازعنك
في الامر وادع الى ربك
وادع الى ربك انك لعلى هدى مستقيم
وان جادلوك فقل الله اعلم بما تعملون
الله يحكم بينكم يوم القيامه فيما كنتم
فيه تختلفون
الم تعلم ان الله يعلم ما في السماء
والارض
ان ذلك في كتاب ان ذلك على الله يسير
ويعبدون من دون الله ما لم ينزل به سلطانا
وما ليس لهم به علم وان وما للظالمين من
نصير
واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا بينات تعرف في
وجوه الذين كفروا المنكر
يكادون يسطون بالذين يتلون عليهم اياتنا
قل افانبئكم
بشر من ذلكم النار
النار وعدها الله الذين كفروا وبئس المصير
يا ايها الناس اضرب مثل فاستمعوا له
ان الذين تدعون من دون الله لن يخلقوا
ذبابا ولو اجتمع معوله
وان يسلبهم الذباب شيئا لا يستنقذوه
منه ضعف الطالب والمطلوب
ما قدروا الله حق قدره
ان الله لقوي عزيز
الله يصطفي من الملائكه
رسلا ومن الناس
ان الله سميع
بصير
يعلم ما بين ايديهم وما خلفهم والى الله
ترجع الامور
يا ايها الذين امنوا اركعوا واسجدوا
واعبدوا ربكم وافعلوا الخير لعلكم تفلحون
الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
وجاهدوا في الله حق جهاده هو اجتباكم وما
جعل عليكم في الدين من حرج مله ابيكم
ابراهيم
هو سماكم
المسلمين من قبل وفي هذا ليكون الرسول
شهيدا عليكم وتكونوا شهداء على الناس
فاقيموا الصلاه واتوا الزكاه واعتصموا
بالله هو مولاكم
هو مولاكم فنعم المولى ونعم النصير ير
الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
استقيم تدل استو
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
والضحى والليل اذا سجى ما ودعك ربك وما
قلى ولا الاخره خير لك من الاولى
ولسوف يعطيك ربك فترضى
الم يجدك يتيما
فاوى
ووجدك ضاننا
فهدى
ووجدك عائلا
فاغنى
فاما
اليتيم فلا تقهر واما
السائل
فلا تنهر
واما
بنعمه ربك فحدث
[Arabic recitation]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين
ارايت الذي يكذب بالدين
فذلك الذي يدع اليتيم
ولا يحض على طعام المسكين
فويل للمصلين
الذين هم عن صلاتهم ساهون
الذين هم يراؤون
ويمنعون
الماعون
[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا الضالين
امين
قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن
كفوا احد
[Arabic recitation]
ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا مباركا
فيه كما تحب وترضى ملء السماء والارض وملء
ما بينهما وملء ما شئت من شيء بعد اهل
الثناء والمجد احق ما قال العبد وكلنا لك
عبد الله لا مانع لما اعطيت ولا معطي لما
منعت
اللهم يا ربنا ويا مولانا ويا سميع الدعاء
يا ذا المن والعطاء يا ذا الجلال الاكرام
يا حي يا قيوم
يا بديع السماوات والارض ويا رحيم الدنيا
والاخره اللهم لا تدع لنا ذنبا الا غفرته
ولا مريضا الا شفيته ولا ميتا من اموات
المسلمين الا رحمته ولا مبتلا الا عافيته
ولا مبتلا الا عاف عفيته ولا ضالا الا
هديته ولا دينا الا قضيته
ولا حاجه من حوائج الدنيا هي لنا خير ولك
رضا الا يسرتها يا رب العالمين اللهم ارحم
ضعفنا اللهم ارحم ضعفنا واجبر كسرنا واجب
دعوتنا
وثبت حجتنا
وسدد السنتنا
واهد قلوبنا
واسلل سخيمه قلوبنا يا رب العالمين اللهم
تقبل منا صلاتنا
وصيامنا
ودعائنا وصالح اعمالنا يا رب العالمين
تقبله خالصا لوجهك الكريم كريم اللهم انا
نسالك من كل خير سالك منه عبدك ورسولك
محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وعبادك الصالحون
ونعوذ بك من كل شر استعاذك منه عبدك
ورسولك محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم وعبادك
الصالحون
نسالك من الخير كله عاجله واجله ما علمنا
منه وما لم نعلم ونعوذ بك من الشر كله
عاجله واجله
ما علمنا منه وما لم نعلم اللهم اصلح لنا
ديننا الذي هو عصمه امرنا واصلح لنا
دنيانا التي فيها معاشنا
واصلح لنا اخرتنا التي اليها معادنا
واجعل اللهم الحياه الدنيا زياده لنا في
كل خير والموت راحه لنا من كل شر اللهم
واجرنا من خزي الدنيا وعذاب الاخره
اللهم اغفر لنا ولوالدينا وللمسلمين
والمسلمات
والمؤمنين والمؤمنات يوم يقوم الحساب
اللهم صل على سيدنا محمد وعلى ال سيدنا
محمد وسلم تسليما كثيرا
واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب العالمين
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Arabic recitation]